The problem here is
that M1 might not halt.
If M1 accepts, then the program is fine.
If M1 rejects, then we'll get to here,
M2 will accept, and D will reject.
That's also correct.
If M1 loops, however,
then this whole program will loop.
Yet we need it to reject in order for
D to decide the language L.
Note that M2 looping can't be a problem
because it can only loop when
x is in the language, but
then M1 would of accepted and
we would have accepted by that point.
Also, if this program returns
any answer, it will be correct.
So both of these are wrong for
that reason.
All right, so
how do we fix this problem of looping?
Well one idea is to run
the two programs parallel, and
accept if M1 accepts,
and reject if M2 does.
Now we can't actually run the two
programs in parallel, but
we can do the next best thing by
switching between the two at every step.
First running a step of M1,
then one of M2, then one of M1, etc.